an austrian brothel
is now bribing men with hookers to take
the fouchy ouchie
from 4 to 10 p.m every monday night the
fun palace cat house is offering men a
30-minute sex session with the
prostitute of their choice
to take the jab
now i know what you're thinking
traditionally [ __ ] houses have not been
considered the pinnacle of public health
but these days up is down and black is
white and so if the whole culture is
turned on its head why not give it a
shot it may not be the most moral way to
promote inoculations but
say what you want about pimps and
prostitutes
at least they're more honest than dr
fauci this austrian hooker story is real
this is a real at first i thought is it
the onion is it the babylon bee no it's
a real story virtually every man i've
told it to by the way have said oh my
god did you see this story about the
austrian brothel that's offering you
hookers for the the jab
their response has been oh my gosh
that's terrible that's awful where is it
where are you just just out of curiosity
where can i find this sort of thing this
is not
not great
you'll you'll cure covid and you'll have
an outbreak of some other problems you
might might need some penicillin at the
very least
what this
shows you is one
the vaccine is not particularly
appealing to a lot of people if the
vaccine were appealing then you wouldn't
need to bribe people with
hookers and cheeseburgers remember bill
de blasio stuffing his face with the
cheeseburgers
eat the slop pigs take the shot and
we'll give you a free slop french fries
you remember that and or bribe you with
money in ohio if you if you let us
inject you with this experimental drug
you could win a million dollars okay
well if the vaccine were appealing you
wouldn't need to bribe people and appeal
to their basest passions and appetites
but then that would require the virus to
be very very scary which it just is not
for the vast majority of people it
doesn't pose much of a threat at all and
so people do not feel the need if this
if this were a bubonic plague breakout
you wouldn't need to bribe people
to get the vaccine and you certainly
wouldn't need to appeal to the prurient
interest and appeal to their basest
passions so it tells you a lot about the
vaccine
and it tells you a lot about the
pandemic that the ruling class thinks
they need to bribe you in this way but
it also tells you a lot about what they
think of you
because
we all have a higher will and we have a
lower will right the higher will is i
want to wake up early and go to
starbucks and do some work and work out
and you know get a head start on my week
and uh fix up fix up things around the
house and write it's and cook dinner
tonight and right that's the that's the
higher will where you're doing things
that are responsible that you think are
virtuous then you've got the lower will
which is i want to go do a bunch of
drugs and eat a bunch of cheeseburgers
and go to the whorehouse and
right that's the lower will and you want
to bring the lower will into discipline
underneath the higher will so you can
suppress those passions and so they're
not appealing to you with
if you um
if you get the jab we'll give you a
scholarship to take a course on
ancient literature
if you
if you get the jab we will
uh i don't know
we will help you in some way to improve
your life and to flourish and to pursue
virtue and to
no it's
we're going to give you something that
is base that is low that is in this case
sinful or that is vicious that that
appeals just to your most basic
most common low
desires because they think that that is
the will that
that controls you you're not you're
actually not in control of your
appetites a free people doesn't get
duped this way okay it's not just the
austrian brothel gimmick
it's it's the money it's the
cheeseburgers it's the
it's the punishment it's that we're
gonna hurt you we're gonna get you fired
we're gonna take your money if you don't
do it
a free people
is not dealt with that way
but increasingly we're not a free people
because we've we've given ourselves over
to our lusts and our passions and our
our ignorance
and our fears and everything that the
left has been ginning up since at least
the 1960s and it tells you not just what
they think of you
it tells you how they rule you
tells you how they govern you
you know this everyone talks about 1984
but this is a lot more like aldous
huxley's brave new world which is about
a dystopian future where the people are
enslaved
not through pain but through pleasure
through drugs and promiscuous sex and
fleeting pleasures and and not not the
real good stuff not the higher stuff but
all the lower stuff that is how they
rule you
okay and it seems nice for the moment
because you want the cheeseburger or you
want the
free money or you want the hooker or
whatever but but it's not going to
fulfill you it's not going to lead to a
flourishing life it's not going to lead
to a flourishing society there are there
are reasons why people don't want to get
the vaccine it's not just stupidity it's
not just ignorance it's not just because
they're anti-science
it's because
there are side effects they had to pause
the johnson and johnson vaccine because
women were dying from blood clots okay
it's it's because the fda and the cdc
have admitted that there are risks of
heart inflammation myocarditis
pericarditis in young healthy
people it's because there are religious
objections
because all of the vaccines were
developed with fetal stem cells aborted
babies and some were produced with them
as well
there are plenty of real objections glad
you like that clip but hold up don't go
anywhere ring that bell subscribe
now even still you might not get those
notifications so what i would really
recommend you go to apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play type in
the michael knowles show
subscribe leave a five star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]